good morning belief nation today's
message is be dedicated to hard work
over to you Robert Duggan first count
the cost of time energy and investment
that would be necessary so when you take
on a project what does this really
entail take a good look at it what does
this mean in terms of the energy and the
outflow so you don't get in over your
head right away but you assess it
properly then become dedicated to hard
work now we all know we all know this
here but this is an interesting word to
the word hard means durable and
persistent and the word work in its
etymology meant completion of intention
so someone would like we had a nice
celebration on Friday that completion of
attention was at an energy spent
completing your intention and you know
that now huh man that's hard work I put
a lot of energy into it but work is a
great word who would want to be denied
the capacity as a human being that you
you you Bob Duggan are a little
different you can never get your
intentions completed for some reason we
just left that ability out well and what
would I you know I'd be reduced to a
tree or to Iraq I couldn't ever move
couldn't turn over unless you kick me
you know but I have the ability to
intend something to intend to help to
intend to create value and so do you so
it's really an important word hard work
so you think
you know I think it's good to be
dedicated to your work although I think
it's hard to describe his hard work if
you really love it I feel like if you
really love it it's not hard work it's
just maybe a lot of work maybe a lot of
dedication about hours but I don't know
if I like the term hard work I think
dedicated that being dedicated to the
work you've loved and do a lot of thing
it's awesome yeah I mean we just having
dinner
I know it's morning for you guys in the
RV dinner and talking about how I don't
like going on beachy vacations because I
get antsy and I want to do something and
I don't have a desire to go and sit on
the beach all day long because I'm not
escaping anything because I love and I
miss the work that I do and I put in an
insane number of hours and the projects
and I'm working but doesn't feel like
I'm doing it you know I think I think it
feels like he was just the problem the
term work like work as a negative
association for me right where when I'm
when I'm when I have something in mind
I'm a dog on a bone and I yeah it's just
like I can't let go until this thing is
done and I'm driving for didn't not
sleeping or whatever it is to accomplish
it I soak up some button what you're
doing not feeling like you're doing a
lot of work but putting putting in the
allergy Network but it you know it feels
like it's you know awesome time that's
life I love it right and you have to be
an expert at your craft you got to put
in the time to make sure you know you
get good at what you're doing but
doesn't you have to feel like work with
guesses right so the question the day
for you guys is what kind of work do you
want to be dedicated to that's cool
leaving the comments below will join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
this recipe Viggo